oh
tu vois il faut pas ouvrir après les
gens ils viennent
savez que votre père a sauvé le statut
sans doute est ce qu'il peut faire pour
vous en faites ce jour à construire une
maison sur son terrain elle avait déjà
d'or évidemment il faut dans un premier
temps puis je dépose une demande de
permis de construire mais vous pouvez
pas lui accorder la hausse pas question
que je me bouge non troppo parce que
j'aime bail verbal - il faudra bien sûr
que j'ai un entrepreneur pour la
construction sega mais ça c'est moi pas
de problème j'ai un cousin qu'elle est
petite équipe c'est quoi ce mur tu vois
pas que plus tendue
c'est eux qui ont fait d'avoir accueilli
monsieur gourdeau là-bas tout ça là où
il ya rien et puisque maintenant il n'y
est plus ce combat parce qu'ici des fois
les maisons saisies sont et d'un coup et
ils sont plus
mais moins éduquées tous les attentats
des attentats non les plasticages louis